(Abdel speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
- As the war in Gaza rages,
violence against Palestinians
in the West Bank is surging.
(person shouting in foreign language)
According to Palestinian villagers,
Israeli settler attacks like these
have been happening almost daily.
So right now, a group of
settlers have kind of moved up
to the road here to try
intimidate the Palestinian farmers
who live on this land.
(people speaking in foreign language)
These guys are coming in
large groups with weapons.
(people speaking in foreign language)
(Abdel speaking in foreign language)
I'm in the town of Qusra in the West Bank.
This is a Palestinian village
where six people were killed
in just a 24-hour period.
The villagers we were talking to here
are saying that the attacks
and intimidation from settlers
has gone into overdrive.
This is one of the bloodiest
periods in the West Bank
in 15 years.
With so much attention focused on Gaza
and focused in the north of the country,
so many of the Palestinians
here are worried
that they will be next
in line to be attacked.
(saw cutting)
At the height of the olive harvest season,
Abdel Azeem Wadi works under
the watch of an IDF outpost.
His family has lived on this
land for three generations.
On October 12th, Abdel was
with his brother Ibrahim
and nephew Ahmed, attending a
funeral for four Palestinians
who had been killed the previous day.
(Abdel person speaking
in foreign language)
(sirens ringing)
(Abdel person speaking
in foreign language)
According to Abdel,
who was just up the road
in the funeral procession,
this video shows armed
settlers stopping their car
and opening fire on Ibrahim and Ahmed.
(gunshots firing)
(camera person grunting)
Hours later, the two men
died at the hospital.
Abdel says they were unarmed.
After the attack, settlers
have since claimed
they had been terrorists,
offering no evidence.
(Abdel speaking in foreign language)
During our interview, a group
of armed Israeli settlers approached.
As the settlers walk
further and further forward,
(dramatic music)
The Israeli military intervenes.
(people speaking in foreign language)
The IDF has stepped in to kind
of pull the settlers back,
so there was no violence.
But the Palestinian people
that we're with here,
the farmers are saying this
is happening almost every day.
(Sara speaking in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
(Abdel speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)